for all hospitals across the country are
closing at the highest rates in decades
since 2010 83 have shut their doors
desperate to stay open some hospitals
got caught up in dubious billing schemes
in March we investigated questionable
billing at rural hospitals in Georgia in
Florida Jim Axelrod is here with new
information on what our CBS News
investigation uncovered Jim good morning
good morning
insurance companies reimburse rural
hospitals at higher rates to help keep
critical health care in those
communities those higher rates have made
rural hospitals attractive targets for
schemes that have generated nearly half
a billion dollars in billing that's
allegedly fraudulent in 2016 Missouri
state auditor Nicole Galloway began
examining the finances of several rural
hospitals in her state
one was button impounding Memorial a 15
bed hospital in Unionville Missouri
struggling to keep its doors open we
were shocked when we started to look at
the financial records and notice that
tens of millions of dollars were coming
through I remember sitting down at the
table with my audit staff and you know I
just said we got to dig deeper on this
her team discovered a management company
called hospital partners had swooped in
weeks before Putnam was about to close
promising to turn it around
they made deals with labs around the
country to funnel billing for blood
tests and drug screens through Putnam
which collects higher reimbursement
rates as a rural hospital Putnam kept
about 15% but most of the money was
wired back to the labs and the
management company essentially the
hospital appeared to act as a shell
company for these questionable lab
Billings how much money are we talking
about in a six month period the hospital
funneled through about 92 million
dollars in revenues to put that in
perspective the previous year their
total revenues were 7.5 million dollars
and it wasn't just happening at Putnam
according to court filings reviewed by
CBS News insurance companies are now
attempting to claw back nearly half a
billion dollars
they paid rural hospitals across the
country with similar billing
arrangements which they call fraudulent
they all declined our request for an
interview and doing health care for the
whole time almost exclusively health
care fraud so we sat down with Jason
Mehta
a former federal prosecutor who
specialized in health care fraud the
questions gonna be did the laboratories
intend to cheat did they intend to trick
did they mislead the insurance companies
because simply making extra money isn't
a crime in and of itself it's the
question of what someone's tricked with
someone deceived insurance companies say
one-way labs deceive them was paying
kickbacks to health care providers for
specimens they could then bill at the
higher reimbursement rates we obtained
this voicemail of a lab representative
soliciting samples from a rehab center
in California he would send about you
know as soon as you guys sent 300
samples he would just any $100,000 right
then it there so I've never heard
usually doesn't do stuff like that if I
had heard that message and we were
talking about Medicare money I would be
very very concerned and I would be
opening an investigation immediately
really seems to skirt a line doesn't it
my experience some of the most
sophisticated actors in this space some
of the ones that get the most amount of
money from the health care programs are
those that know exactly where the line
is and start right up to that line what
may Ted told us could cross the line is
a key finding of Nicole Galloway's on it
several months after the questionable
lab Billings had started there was no
operating lab in the hospital how could
they be billing for lab tests lab work
if there was no lab in the hospital
that's exactly what we questioned in
March
Blue Cross filed a 60 million dollar
lawsuit against Hospital partners
alleging their arrangement with labs was
a fraudulent scheme hospital partners is
suing galloway claiming she had no right
to audit putnam it is clear that
hospital partners did not like our audit
they did not like us shining a light on
the issues that we identified they sued
you they
they are pushing back on us but I will
tell you that will not stop me from
doing my job on behalf of taxpayers in a
statement hospital partners said Putnam
County Memorial Hospital is authorized
by law to a-sine and bill for clinical
laboratory testing provided at a
reference lab but just yesterday the
Missouri Attorney General's Office told
us it is actively investigating this
matter so Jim I have a question for you
that hot Hospital yeah Putnam County
Memorial Hospital it's still open it is
for now but we have seen similar cases
where insurance companies cut off
payments to the rural hospitals and that
creates a sort of circle the drain
situation the hospitals have to close
those communities are left without
health care be interesting after they
see your report what happens mm-hmm yeah
very impressive Jim thank you